on
well let's see if he's still paul ryan's
still there now paul ryan is trending
how in the [ __ ] is this news
how the [ __ ] is it news that paul ryan
goes on an interview
on wsn12
and says president trump lost in 2020
yeah no [ __ ] [ __ ] sherlock
are you kidding me
that's [ __ ] news
we have to this is trending people let's
see it's trending in the united states
united states paul ryan is training
number 13 in politics number 13 because
he said the last president who lost my 8
million votes lost
what the [ __ ]
jesus
these [ __ ] pace eaters man i think
that's what i'm gonna call them down you
know i call them i call them i call them
shitty ears a lot
because that's what they are as she
eaters but i think what i'm gonna call
them
a lot now from now on
is call them paste eaters instead of
[ __ ] eaters
or maybe it's horseshit eaters i don't
know
i don't know what do you guys think do
you think [ __ ] eaters
paste eaters horseshit eaters it's kind
of hard to tell really so paul ryan
let's go see if we get some good
some good tweets in the uh the paul ryan
category
uh mayo is always getting good at what
she had to say paul ryan is right about
trump losing in 20 the 2020 election
but he's still a fox news loving douche
okay yep
that's good enough for me
it's good enough to be on my tl
thanks mayo